肇社長の仕事がない24時間密着動画です
最近さん寝るを休止していた間にあり今日
何もなくねという日があったのでもし
youtube とは仕事が無かったら
どうなるのかちょっと密着してみました
この日は朝9時に起きました ua
なかなかにを吹かすしていたのであまり
睡眠時間はたないとはいえません
動きましたね
昨日の夜はですねあのムエタイの試合をし
ていたわけではないんですけれどもこう
いう服装で埋めていました
寝起きはいいので結構カットを着れる感じ
です
何が良かったのでしょうか
分かりませんがまずはしっかり1日の準備
をしていきましょう
[音楽]
10分ぐらいでなんとなくシャワーを浴び
て
果たして服を着るという名前になってい
ます
結構髪だけは短いのでささっとあのパット
とも言えます
全然変わってませんねん
ぐちゃん朝ごはんですねコンビニの物を
全部買い占めてしまったので家の中でご飯
は完結します
今日はコアラのマーチとポイグロを撮り
ましたん
こうラーメンとかほぼなくなってしまった
のでおかしい
体にはよくないと思うんですけどもお菓子
をメインに朝ごはんは食べています
心配ですねでも美味しいので ok です
ん
他には
これだけにしとこって感じですねさあ午前
中の厨二です何もなかったら肇社長は何を
するのかというとアニメをずっと見てい
ます
これは僕のヒーローアカデミアですね第4
期
チャンネル抽出中に1期から5期まで全部
見させていただきまして今はとても
盛り上がっているシーンを見ているところ
です
やっていい
風に泣いてますね最高ですかにょん
お昼の13時ですねこの時間からちょっと
用事で東京に向かっております
マンボウ by でした確か一さん
うん
源さん
はいなぜかカメラがすごい話かけてきて
おります
源さんライダーうん d 生活
せつげっ
カメラはでしょ
あじゃさんは趙雲でしたか
本当に手術させ湿原に伝えいただきますん
始めさあ
ついたらだいたい270くらいですね2な
なぜ彼らが個室のサウナに入っております
動画でも言った通り僕も人がいっぱいいる
三田には行かないんですけれども
個室のサウナで最近は整っております
道やすごい先生は言えばいい2敗
点数や恋すごい
上が失礼
[音楽]
最近は商品たっサウナんですよねー
昭通水しっかりと水風呂に入った後は中継
ですここで整います
整う骨としてなら体の今足をクローズし
たりな家具で置いたりその1出会いは客
向きをされて足もちょっと一応書いて腕も
戻しました足をもう一回戻していきだけ
ました
あこの状態ですね
[音楽]
今日はこれが整うしてです気によって整う
姿勢が違うのでいつもそれを避けるのみ
だいたい12分ほど要してしまいます
後半をやってきましたね
二人で静かにサウナで個室サウナで整って
いうのが休みの日の肇社長です
iphone にそして21時です東京の
お家に帰ってきてねpc で最近リリース
されたいう技をマスターディールをやって
います
今回販売され
[音楽]
を杖で廃止ません相手の顔が見えないこと
をいいことにあのかなり煽りながらプレイ
しております遊戯王カード大好きなんです
けども遊ぶ友達が少なかったのでこうして
ネットを通じていろんな人とデールできる
のは本当にありがたいです
もう最近時間があったり暇だったら
バスターディールを本当になってますね
はい
あの気づいたら
朝になってました
あっは
[音楽]
bl